Some brothers are going for double time
today.
[Arabic recitation]
[Silence]
asks the prophet Sam,
"Tell me about the signs,
the indicators of the day of judgment,
of the hour drawing Near
the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
mentions two. The first one he says
that a slave girl would give birth to
her own mistress or give birth to her
own master in one wording. Yesterday or
yesterday morning we mentioned three
explanations for this statement.
three potential explanations for this
statement and we mentioned that all
three are valid and all three have
occurred in the history of this
mighty let's see if we remember those
three anyone remember the first meaning
of
the first meaning that we mentioned that
a woman would give birth to her own
mistress. Give birth to her own master.
[Silence]
[Arabic recitation]
trying really hard and your brothers
have forsaken you. Not one of them is
trying to help you.
I just want you to see that this is what
happens. You see, you start talking and
everybody stares at the back of your
head.
[Arabic recitation]
would be a slave taken as a prisoner of
war by the mighty armies of Islam and
her children would be would be free by
default and so they would be born
emancipated
even if she remains a slave and this is
an indicator that Islam would stretch in
its empire and in its reach. So that
happened. The second one
that due to the muddling of
of lineage and due to the fact that
people are not keeping track of their
lineage.
A woman may be purchased by her own son
or daughter as a slave literally not
knowing that this is the mother not
knowing that this is the daughter or son
and this occurred as well. Those are
two. The third is figurative, right?
that a woman would be a figurative slave
to her child who is figuratively her
master. Meaning the child would behave
and fill the role of master and the
parent will fulfill the role of slave
dutiful dutiful servant. Why? due to the
overreach of tyrannical governments near
the end of time and the breaking up of
the family unit. Correct? This as well
happened. I mean the time we're living
in is is is pretty indicative of that.
So these are three meanings. The next
one he mentions, he says
the second one he mentions is that you
would observe the barefoot, naked and
poor, impoverished
shepherds of sheep
competing with one another in building
their high buildings. Right? Remember
we mentioned this before and that is
that anytime we take a statement by
default it is literal. Correct? By
default. But
literal doesn't always mean that there
is no metaphorical meaning as well.
Right? So
literal meaning that this literally
occurred but metaphorical meaning as
well that the ri the very poor
throughout time will suddenly come into
obscene amounts of wealth overnight.
Overnight a person will come from a
lineage of poor men and suddenly
overnight he becomes so wealthy that he
is competing with others in skyscrapers
in building skyscrapers right and this
kind of wealth
usually wealth that is real wealth okay
this is not a good thing sometimes We
look at a society and we say, "Oh, you
know, if you, you know, the
American dream, the American dream,
which brought most of us here to this
country in the first place, right? The
advertisement that, you know, you come
to America and it's the land of the
hopes and dreams come true." You know,
everyone has a fair shake. Everyone
starts at the same start line. And if
you work hard, you'll become really rich
and you can become really rich
overnight. And you know, things can
suddenly change for you. This, if it
were true, which it's not, but if it
were really true, is not indicative of
true wealth. Wealth is something that
has to be brought up
generationwise.
It has to be built up over generations.
This is why it is incredibly rare in the
previous that somebody would come
from a a poor family or what we call
middle class family and become obscenely
rich. This is almost unheard of because
it is momentum. It's trying
to push something that's very heavy. You
have to get it started and it takes a
long time. It takes generations to build
up wealth.
That wealth is strong. It doesn't
disappear in a heartbeat, right? You
compare that to something the stock
market.
The stock market, a person is poor. They
happen to just stumble upon the right
stock at the right time at the right
place and suddenly they are a
millionaire. They are a billionaire.
Right? But just as suddenly as that
money came, it can also just as suddenly
what? disappear and vanish because what
comes with ease and quickness goes with
ease and quickness.
And so this is not indicative of a
strong economy. This is not indicative
of a fair game or a fair economic
landscape. This is indicative of
people
sha doing shady things behind the
scenes to make these things happen. The
prophet sallallah.aii wasallam tells us
that men who are by default barefoot,
naked, right? shepherds of sheep.
They haven't even gotten a chance to
get rid of the of the old image that
they had of being a poor shepherd. They
are not cultured of of generations of
wealth. Yet they come into money
overnight. Overnight they're wealthy.
Obscenely wealthy. So obscenely wealthy
that they are now building skyscrapers
and competing with one another who can
touch the sky the best and the fastest.
This here
this here articulates that near the end
of time economies will be very rigged.
Wealth will not be generational and
people will be living life at a
breakneck speed. Things will happen
overnight. And the prophet sallall.aii
alaihi wasallam tells us that time will
come when even iman and kufur will be
this man will wake up a believer go
to sleep a disbeliever
go to sleep a dis a believer wake up a
disbeliever
these are uncertain times you would not
expect
the barefoot naked shepherds of sheep
which Which why does he specify sheep?
Shepherds. There are many types of
shepherds. Correct? Cattle, camels,
sheep, goats, llamas in certain parts of
the world, right? Why specifically
sheep? Because sheep are the
most humble
or should we say they are the they
are the least wealthy from amongst the
shepherds. Shepherds of camels are
usually incredibly wealthy people,
right? Shepherds of livestock like
cattle, very wealthy people. Sheep,
shepherds, most people dabble in being a
shepherd for sheeps. most people even
poor people and so the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam is telling us
here that men that don't even have shoes
on their feet don't even have clothing
on their backs are suddenly overnight
falling into the honeypot the proverbial
honeypot and becoming so obscenely
wealthy
that they are now competing in
skyscrapers in in building these what
they call skyscrapers,
right, in Arabic. And we see the
ignorance here because few things in
this world are more deadly and
detrimental to a person and society in
general as wealth mixed with ignorance.
These two things come together, the most
terrible things in human history occur
because of these two things combining.
Wealth is societal power. That's what it
is. It's power.
And ignorance and power do not mix.
When you have a very ignorant man with a
lot of power, this is the most dangerous
kinds of people.
These are the most dangerous kinds of
people not only to themselves but also
to society
right. They destroy
ino and in their mind they are
right. And so we see the ignorance of
these men because what are they spending
their money on?
Skyscrapers. building the tallest
building, which people know that
buildings when they get to a certain
height, they're all but useless
function-wise,
right? Most of these super tall,
fabulous buildings that countries boast
about, they're empty inside and they
just suck up electricity, suck up
resources, take a lot of maintenance and
an obscene amount of wealth. It is pure
vanity.
It is pure vanity. And so these men will
fall into wealth overnight. And what did
they spend the wealth on? Ignorance.
Trying to touch the sky. Trying to show
everyone and prove to everyone that he
is a big man because he has a big
building. When that doesn't mean that he
is a big man. That means he's a very
small man who knows deep down that he's
very small and he's afraid everyone else
sees it. Right? This
is one of the dangers of society at the
end of times. The breakdown of society
and the mixture of ignorance and wealth.
And we're not speaking about just little
bit of wealth. We're talking about
obscene amounts of wealth. Now a lot of
times when this narration is mentioned
it's applied to which region in our time
tell us huh
the Gulf yes the Gulf what they call
the Gulf states right say
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
was speaking about these these you know
besa over in the Gulf states right Saudi
and Kuwait and and and and and alat
and dub and while that may be applicable
that is not specific that is not
specific to them nor is it a general
dispraise of the people from the Gulf
state
right it is not necessarily only the
Gulf state and it's not necessarily
Muslims who will suffer from this this
doesn't specify that it will be Muslims
who will suffer from this. It mentions
people of that caliber which will fall
into immense amounts of wealth and that
applies to people from anywhere in the
world. Even if it may also apply to some
from the Gulf States, it is not
particular to the Gulf States. Nor is it
a dispraise from the prophet
sallallah.aii alaihi wasallam directed
at the Gulf States. The prophet
sallallahu
says and we will finish with this.
The man then got up and left.
Omar says,
"Huh?
for
[Silence]
It was three days later
means I then spent the next period, the
next few days in certain narrations,
three days wondering about the
curious about this encounter.
Why did the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam leave them for three days
to finally say this was Jirel?
What is the reason for that? You would
expect that as soon as he left he would
say this is but he didn't. The man left
they he went on with his day
spent three days until the prophet
finally said to him
after three days he said to Omar do you
know who the questioner was
I said Allah and his messenger know
He said that was Jirel. He came to teach
you your religion. Why three days?
He wanted to let the students chew on it
and work it over in their minds. You
cannot spoon feed knowledge to someone
who is not hungry. The more hunger
builds,
the more the student will consume
the knowledge. And so to build that
hunger,
he left it for a day, two days, three
days. This is all he's thinking about.
Who was that man? Where did he go when
he left? In the narration of Abu Huray,
when the man got up and left, Abu Huray
said, the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
said
when he left and walked out of the
doors, the prophet said to the
companions that were sitting there,
"Tell that man to come back."
said, "We went out to find him and he
was gone. Just disappeared." The man
vanished.
I mean, imagine that situation, right? A
man comes in, jet black hair,
really white clothing. No one has ever
seen this man before. And he clearly did
not come from elsewhere.
He comes in the middle. No fear, no
embarrassment amongst all of these
companions sit so close to the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam. His knees
are touching his knees and he says,
[Arabic recitation]
listening because you're not supposed to
talk to the prophet that
sallall.aii wasallam." This is the
behavior of the bedins who don't know
better. the kind of bedins that would
come into the masid and perhaps urinate
in a corner. However, this man was not
an ignorant man. He's saying, "Yeah,
Muhammad." Yet, at the same time, he's
saying
after he's finished telling him about
Islam, he tells him, "You know what?
You're right. That's correct. Now, tell
me about
and
you're correct. Now tell me about what
is this guy? Where is this guy from?
What is this? It's it's creepy. It's
bizarre.
And then the man gets up and leaves. And
as soon as he walks out the door,
he'd vanished. He's gone. This isn't
he got in a car and drove down the
street, right? You can see as far as the
eye can see in the desert. The man is
not there. He is gone. as if he was
plucked up from the sky.
And so this builds that curiosity, that
hunger. Now when he says that was Gibl,
every single word and movement that
Girrel made now becomes of consequence.
And it is etched into their minds until
the day they die. And it was so
compelling that they will tell their
children and their children's children.
Because this narration comes to us also
from who? Omar. Omar went home and told
his family, told his son, "Come here.
Let me teach you something happened
today.
[Silence]
I'm sending out spies to make sure you
guys don't have trees in your house.
[Arabic recitation]